all right the last talk of this session
will be by Christian Mayans on catalytic
decoupling a different title and the
thing here catalytic decoupling oh I see
it's two talks that have been joined
together into one so join with
deconstruction and conditional erasure
of correlations thank you yeah thanks
for the introduction and I want to thank
this the organizers for giving me the
opportunity to to give this talk yeah as
as mentioned this is the merge talk of
these two papers which is joint work
with some quite some people Mario bears
offset Dupree Donato venema cheers
Kristen bluefin and Oakland ow and Mark
rudy and yeah it kind of makes a lot of
sense that these were have been merged
to me because they are just too
generalizations of the same concept so
what I'm going to do now is first
introduced that concept and then
continue to present the two
generalizations and that concept is
decoupling or a very very closely
related concept is erasure of
correlations and these what I want to
present now first to as in or explained
in an introduction so we can go on to
generalize them so what is decoupling
the decoupling technique is that
basically boils down to the idea to
destroy correlations between two quantum
systems by only acting on one of them
with the local noisy quantum channel and
this has been a very useful proof tool
in many areas of quantum information
theory and beyond like for example
quantum Shannon theory thermal
dynamics solid-state physics and also
black hole radiation although i don't
understand that very very much but I've
been told so at least and so if we look
at the details it's it's very maybe a
very instructive to explain the the
exact protocol in this pictorial way so
we start out with the bipartite quantum
system that has two parts a and E and
the this bipartite quantum system is in
some mixed a draw a e now we subdivide
the system a into two parts a one and A
two and we apply a unitary to the a
system here and then we take the partial
trace over a two this is basically the
noisy part of the map and then if we did
everything right then the remaining
system a one is in a product this state
with system e and now of course the
question the information theorist asks
now is how do big do we have to choose
this a 2 system that we are getting rid
of to achieve this task to render the
system product afterwards because just
as a sanity check and there exists some
size of a to that achieves this because
if we chase choose a two to be all of a
then it's it's trivial trivially it
ceased for for any unit with unitary and
as it turns out and the the relevant
quantity here is the quantum mutual
information at least in the in the so
called asymptotic or iid setting so that
is the setting where the quantum state
we are looking at is a tensor power it's
just many independent copies of another
quantum state Sigma so then
the optimal the optimal size of this
system a to that we got rid of is equal
to the quantum you to information in
first order in n and this was
essentially first observed by her desk a
oppenheim inventor in their work on
state merging and they had it in a
slightly different form but essentially
it's it's equivalent so this gives us an
operational interpretation of the
quantum mutual information and this is
very nice because and although the
quantum mutual information is easily
generalized by just generalizing the
classical formula it's not clear a
priori whether the interpretation
generalizes as well so slightly before
before that work on state merging and
there was a work by grossmont popescu
and winter where they introduced a task
that's called a razor of correlations
and that is very similar to 2d coupling
and accept that they didn't apply to
anything any other and any other tasks
but they considered the erasure of
correlations the task itself so let's
look at this in detail and it's almost
it's basically almost the same as before
we start with the bipartite quantum
system here the touch parts a and E but
in this time we instead of a partial
trace as a noisy map we apply a
so-called random unitary channel which
consists of choosing a set of 2 to the K
unit aires and then basically flipping k
coins and and so randomly choosing one
of the two to the K unit aires and then
we hope that afterwards the system ends
up in a product state of course the
question again is how big do we have to
choose k here
and to achieve yet to do it's Eve this
task and it turns out the answer is
almost the same in the asymptotic
setting and we need a number basically
an amount of noise in this process that
is again equal to the to the quantum
user information and yeah this is of
course an operational interpretation of
it and this should not be considered
very surprising in in the sense that
decoupling and erasure of correlations
are really actually more or less two
sides of the same coin so if we have a
protocol for decoupling then we get 144
for erasure of correlations and the
other direction becomes true under
slight generalization of the task that
we will see later so this was the
introduction to the coupling and erasure
of correlations and now I want to to
continue by generalizing this these
paradigms in two ways so first I want to
present a one-shot generalization of
this which we call catalytic decoupling
and here this quantum mutual information
this familiar quantity is replaced by a
one-shot version of it which is called
the mass mutual information and and then
we can do I will continue in the second
part to generalize decoupling to the
setting with quantum site information
and here and perhaps not very
surprisingly the quantum conditional
mutual information plays the role of of
the relevant information theoretic
quantity
okay let's start with the with catalytic
decoupling and so to motivate our work
on catalytic decoupling let me present
some previous work and so this is a
actually this is a one-shot decoupling
theorem baidu prebiotic world flicker
and Rena and so it reads like this if we
have a bipartite quantum state and then
we want to to the couple a from E and we
shoot some decomposition of a into two
parts a one and A two and then if we
choose a to large enough according to
this lower bound that that I will
explain in a second then there exists
unitary such that if we take if we apply
the unitarian take subsequently the
partial trace over a 2 then the system
ends up in an approximate product state
however notice that this doesn't only
simply achieve that the system is in a
product state but what is more the
decouple part of the system this a 1
here is in a maximally mixed state and
this is also reflected by the fact that
we get as a cost function here as this
minimal size of a 2 we get a difference
of smooth rainy and trapeze and
basically the unconditional versions of
this rainy entropies i defined in this
in this little graphic here so this is
the spectrum of some quantum state role
and and the min entropy is the negative
of the logarithm of the maximum value
where the max entropy is the logarithm
of the size of the support of the
spectrum and these epsilon this little
epsilon this show
this is shows that this is a smooth
version of so-called smooth version of
the reigning entropy which means that
the quantities are optimized over an
epsilon ball around the state row so in
particular because of the definition of
the of these quantities this difference
here can be very large even in cases
where the true system should actually be
considered decoupling decoupled and that
is if we have a product state already
between a and E but maybe the system a
is in a state that's very far from a
mixtape from a from a maximally next day
in comparison if we take the situation
for the iid situation again then this
lower bound here as as I as I said we'll
just be in terms of the quantum user
information and this has the all the
properties that we want it becomes 0 for
product states and also it can be shown
that this is optimal okay so there has
been some previous work overcoming the
problem that I that I described in the
last few slides and that is in the in
the in the specific application of one
short quantum state merging I have not
explained what this is this wants a
quantum state merging but let me anyway
present or like mention these results
and to basically be able to refer to
them later oh sorry so Patrick Istanbul
and Deanna they showed that that well
once your quantum state merging is
actually possible with a quantum
communication cost that is proportional
to this max mutual information which
will play the important the important
role in the characterization of
catalytic decoupling and they use the
standard decoupling theorem that I
and it presented to you in the last few
slides but on top of that they need a
concept called embezzling States which
was introduced by fundament Hayden and
then there was some some more recent
work improving over over this bound in
the lower order term here by answered by
batini and Jane actually their work is
on stage redistribution and even more
complicated task and but it also has
this corollary about one shot state
merging and it uses a completely
different technique that's called a
convex convex split lemma and so these
were basically like tailored fixes to
the problem that i present it in the
application of in these quantum Shenton
theoretic applications and now what we
were able to do is somehow they still
these these these fixes into an or and
unify them into a generalized decoupling
paradigm that works in the one-shot
setting this is what we call catalytic
decoupling and generalizes decoupling in
two ways and on the one hand we drop
this this condition that X decoupling
the decoupled system should be in a
maximally mixed state and on the other
hand we also allow that before the
decoupling procedure is started and a
mixed and salah state is appended so to
solve this in this pictorial way as I
have presented the the previous concepts
we start with this by protect want some
system again with systems a and E but
this time we append some some some
product system a prime in in some fixed
state and now we continue in the same
way as in regular decoupling we divide
this joint system AAA prime into two
integer bars a1 and a2 we apply a
unitary
and we take the partial trace over a two
and we hope that afterwards the the
system is in a product state and not
here that it's very important that we
focus on the size of this system a to
that we trace out because and if we
would focus on the on the size of the
system that is decoupled here that we
could make arbitrary large but by just
appending a large ancilla but we focus
on this on the system the size of the
system that we take the trace over and
that is basically the corresponds to the
amount of noise we have to inject and
that that there we have we expect to get
a lower bound for that for that yeah the
question is of course how big do we have
to choose a to indicate in this
generalized case and this would be
smaller than in the case of regular
decoupling because we have relaxed the
conditions we have like given us more
opportunities to what kind of operations
to apply by it by appending this and
Cilla and we have dropped this condition
of randomization so this this new
paradigm can be can be completely
characterized now and that's what we've
done and we if we again start with the
bipartite quantum state row AE and then
we pick some accuracy for for the
decoupling then catalytic decoupling
with this accuracy epsilon can be
achieved with the remainder system size
log a to that's approximately equal to
one-half times the maximum the smooth
max mutual information and this max
mutual information now this may be time
to give give a definition this is
defined in terms of this max divergence
or max relative entropy and
and it involves this minimization here
and the max max relative entropy is just
defined in terms of this minimization of
the simple operator into inequality and
this app little epsilon here this
signifies that this is a smooth version
again which means that this quantity
here is minimized over an epsilon ball
around the state row and I said log a2
is approximately equal to this side to
this quantity but yeah to be more
precise this means up to terms that are
much lower if the dimensions go up we
also can provide a converse statement
which means that catalytic decoupling is
impossible whenever we try to do it with
mud with a smaller system a 2 then one
half times the max mutual information
and so I mentioned that this is unifying
these two previously exist existent
techniques and this is reflected in the
fact that we have two proofs of this
theorem where one using with using the
techniques from these two works
respectively
okay so maybe I should go quickly
through this slide to get to the second
part and so we can show an asymptotic
equipartition property that is we
recover the the statement about regular
decoupling in the asymptotic setting and
this shows that in the in this case the
Installer becomes it becomes unnecessary
and the randomization condition is
redundant which is also to be expected
because the marginals in their synthetic
setting are anyway have a flat spectrum
and because we get a quite tight
characterization of this task we can
also give a second second order term in
the asymptotic expansion in terms of
this mutual information variance and
yeah and the usual inverse community
cumulative normal distribution and as
promised in this in this case with
ancilla this unitary a random unitary
channel model and the partial trace
model are completely equivalent okay
this was the first part of the talk so
let's move on to the second part which
we call conditional erasure of
correlations and and this is now
completely different setting here we
stay in the in the asymptotic setting of
many independent identically distributed
copies of some state but we add quantum
site information so this week means we
are talking about tripartite quantum
states row a ER and there we have the so
called quantum conditional mutual
information which is given by this
formula and it has the property that it
measures conditional correlations
between a and E conditioned on our and
in the following very precise sense that
was basically
[Music]
discovered by fossee and renner and and
that is that if we just look at a
tripartite quantum state here row AEI
and now maybe we lose the system a so we
only have row e are left now we try the
following we just try to recover a the
system that we lost by only applying a
quantum channel 2i and the this quantum
channel we also call are usually because
it's called it's a recovery channel and
then in the case where this quantum
mutual information here is small the
quantum conditional mutual information
then we can achieve that this recovered
state is approximately equal to the
original state and in this pictorial in
this picture these lines they are
supposed to to be correlations and you
can see because we were able to
reproduce the state by just operating on
our this line here somehow vanished and
we couldn't recover it so it seems like
or that's the case and it hasn't even
been there in the in the beginning so
there's no direct correlations between a
and a and E in other words all
correlations between a and E are some
are mediated through our and in this
case in this case where this recovery is
possible we say that e to our to a is an
approximate quantum Markov chain
yeah as I said this is just to conclude
that I that is quantum conditional
mutual information here measures
conditional correlations in this very
precise ends so recall that this ratio
of correlations that I presented in the
introduction and the task means needs an
amount of noise that's equal to the
quantum you to information so a natural
question is of course can we erase
conditional correlations as measured by
the quantum good as neutral information
by injecting an amount of noise into the
a marginal that is proportional to this
this quantum condition mutual
information unfortunately this is not
the case there's even a classical
counterexample to to the to this idea
and which is kind of quite simple but
unfortunately a bit too it takes to be
too long to explain for for this short
talk what is more there's some previous
work by waka cord which characterizes
this task this this task of raising the
conditional correlations by locally
acting on on this a system here and but
they they were able to characterize it
in in terms of some function that's
discontinuous in terms of the quantum
state and in general much larger than
the quantum condition neutral
information
and however if you think of the
classical case there's one situation
which is one modification of the task
where it's obvious that we can some
ourselves our idea of finding an
operational interpretation of the
quantum condition boots information and
that is by basically instead of applying
a local just a local operation on a we
apply an operational and conditioned on
our because if we condition on our then
we are back in the in the classical case
then we are back in the bipartite
setting okay so let me quickly introduce
the task of quantum state redistribution
because that's what we will need for
characterizing conditional erasure of
correlations and so this is a task where
we have two players Alice and Bob and a
referee r & Ellis has two quantum system
C and a bob has a quantum system B and
the referee has this quantum system are
and the global state is pure so their
task is that Ellis wants to send her
system a to Bob why she can operate it
on a on a and C but the task is to keep
for four LS is to keep c and send a to b
to achieve this task they can also use
some entangled resource here and what it
was nice about this this task which is
which one could also call a quantum
source coding with site information at
both the encoder and the decoder is that
the optimal communication rate that is
necessary for else to send this system
is given by the conditional quantum user
information this was shown by David takn
yan so after this little internet so let
let let come back to to our task of
conditional arisia and there we have
this this tripartite quantum state and
and now we just introduced the concept
of a quantum conditional operation
on air conditioned on our and for this
we slightly relaxed the classical idea
by saying that we operate on AR but we
want to leave the re marginal
approximately unchanged on top of this
as in catalyzing decoupling we allow a
pending in asila so in this in this
explaining this pictures again we have
the tripartite quantum system with with
systems AE and I now we append Anna
Scylla we apply unitary to these three
systems ra na prime but under the
condition that these e and are the joint
er system here is approximately
unchanged after that we continue like
before we subdivide the a systems into
two parts a1 and a2 take the partial
trace / a2 and then hopefully we have
achieved our task of of conditional
ratio of correlations but actually there
are kind of two different tasks that's
that one at two different results one
could ask for one of them is to render
as as as described in on a few slides
ago to render Ito I to a-1 an
approximate quantum Markov chain that is
to make this a one system here
recoverable from our but we could also
ask something stronger where we ask each
one to be completely in a product state
with this er system and the first task
we call the construction of correlations
and the second task we call conditional
ratio of correlations and of course the
second one implies the first one because
a product that is for sure recoverable
and now we were we're able to
characterize this in a asymptotic
setting where we show that conditional
eraser the stronger task here is
equivalent to quantum state
redistribution we're basically
communication rate in the quantum state
redistribution case you translates into
noise rate in the condition of the razor
case also we have a convent for the
weaker task which matches the direct
statement for the stronger task so that
means that these book these two tasks
you have both the same optimal noise
rate asymptotically and we ended up with
with the new operational interpretation
of the quantum conditional mutual
information okay so we're at the last
light what did we do today we
generalized the decoupling paradigm or
erasure of correlations to two new
settings which is the or two to two
different settings one is the one shot
setting here where the max mutual
information replaced the mutual
information and then also to the setting
with site information where the
conditional neutral quantum conditional
mutual information was the relevant
quantity and these two generalizations
have some applications so cat alerting
the kaplan can can be used to give a
simple proof for the achievability of
once at state merging and the
conditional erasure of correlations
paradigm can be used to give operational
interpretations of the quantum discord
and squashed entanglement okay this this
is it thanks for your attention and I'm
open to your questions
[Applause]
ok questions
so in cattle a catalytic decoupling do
you require that en Cielo is returned in
the same stage or what is catalytic
about it so em somehow we so there
there's two ways first we can we can
actually hand in hand back the insula in
approximately same the same state with
the same approximate quality as as at
the whole the cat decoupling procedure
yeah a bit the same area as the
decoupling works and this is of course
not català tissa t in the in the
thermodynamic sense because this sent
this way like this the distance notion
we use is the trace distance this and
then you basically for life systems do
you get you can do a lot of things in
thermodynamics if if you allow small
trace distance area
other questions
theres the mic is his right on its way I
was just wondering how large these
catalysts need to be in order for the
theorems to work that is a very good
question and and we have we have
basically way I have to say we have no
idea how large they have to be so our
achievability results use huge catalysts
however we don't even have a proof that
that it is necessary the catalyst
for questions also it may be a maybe i
can send will say one more sentence
about this and one interesting question
is let's assume the catalyst is
necessary in the single chart setting
then of course you get the finite block
length question we're basically your
intermediate regime where your one shot
protocol requires huge amount of offense
allah and but you should be approaching
the asymptotic setting whether in zilla
definitely becomes unnecessary so yeah
this is also something that may be
interesting to look at question
just ask a very naive question you
mentioned that the decoupling techniques
were used as proof techniques in quantum
Shannon theory and another area so with
these new results what what uh further
applications what new kinds of things
with these let you prove so somehow as i
said the catalyst Linkin coupling can be
used for this single shot quantum state
merging but this this result is not new
it has been proven before just now we
can prove it in the same way as in the
asymptotic setting because we have this
catalytic decoupling that we can apply
black box beyond that I mean conditional
erasure is its equivalent to quantum
state merging a quantum state
redistribution so actually can be used
to prove achievability of condensate
redistribution and but beyond that we we
didn't we didn't find for now any any
further information theoretic
applications for that other questions
people are looking hungry I guess so to
keep people from I just observe it just
occurred to me that the speakers at this
conference are the red shirts but I'm
sure there's nothing to worry about so
thank you very much let's thank Chris
Young again and all of the speakers
you